thanks for joining us America we're glad
you're here Russ is with us in Salem
Massachusetts hey Russ welcome to the
Dave Ramsey show better than I deserve
how are you I am good Dave I've posted
some things on your website in regard to
insurance philosophies you put online
and having been an insurance broker for
about 35 years there are a few
misstatements that are on there that I'd
like to use the air as a chance to maybe
there clarify with you or maybe get some
clarity from you on may I do that sir
okay number one you have said on your
website that term insurance is the best
and the only kind of product people
should buy in all instances where they
need life insurance and what I can tell
you is that we do not recommend like
whole life insurance across the boards
we recommend life insurance
situationally there's no - needs no -
situations but a pervasively similar
okay can you hear me all right yeah I'm
hearing okay number two but cash value
that you've talked about did you want me
to address that one first it's up to you
okay so you'd like to I'll be happy to
do it one other time well you're an
insurance agent obviously and the I
disagree when you say there are no two
instances that are the same there are
basic principles of mathematics and
basic principles of personal finance
that are always the same for instance I
would tell you there is never a time
that you would use a credit card you
can't say that there and you can't
convince me that there's certain times
you should use a credit card they suck
they're a bad product they don't work
and I think the same thing is true of
whole life all right well let's take it
a little bit further number two you know
there seems to be some question about
the cash value of a life insurance
policy as being a bad investment and I
won't get into the issue of performance
but I think the big thing that you need
to realize is this the cash value is not
there because insurance companies are
creating
a standard of return or investment that
is deemed to be you know is deemed to be
poor or is deemed to be immovable but
cash backs and why would you do it
Elysee is there it's a function of law
it involved so why would you put extra
money into a policy to create cash value
if the cash value is has no standard of
excellence at all on the rate of return
well you didn't let me finish those
policies historically get better as they
get older
okay the cash value of a life insurance
policy is a function of state law it's a
function of statutory reserves sir and
also from an actuarial standpoint it's
used to keep premiums level indefinitely
why do you think term insurance is so
cheap because term insurance does not
have or maintain a legal reserve a fix
to it
sure does they have to have it they have
to have cash reserves to support
otherwise the state won't license the
term insurance company now it's a
20-year level term 20-year level term
insurance is about one fifth or about
120th the cost about five percent the
cost at the same amount the same amount
of whole life is actually your right but
from an actuarial point of view whole
life is considered to be a product
priced indefinitely that does not have
but it never stays in place indefinitely
that depends upon the person and that
does on the situation the person
although all the research shows that
they cash them out like crazy vast
majority do but let's just pretend you
kept it for your whole life why the why
the flip that you needed for your whole
life how about some things called estate
taxes there are people who do when they
die see their family incur a substantial
substantial financial loss and so in
order to cover estate taxes I need to
get ripped off for sixty years and a
horrible financial product that's your
turn you know if you talk about the dirt
you talk about the difference of
investments why don't you talk about the
difference and for example in attorneys
fees their attorneys are cheques $300 an
hour versus four seven hundred dollars
an hour you don't tell somebody to
invest the difference in legal fees to
see if they come out ahead do you of
course I would if the actual if the
actual legal advice was exactly the same
well
if you die you get paid with term
insurance your beneficiary gets paid
pretty simple formula if you die with
whole life life insurance your
beneficiary gets paid only the face
amount after you've paid 20 times more
policy I can refute that very easily you
can it is a ray if it if a policy is
arranged properly a person can receive
not just but face amount of the policy
but in addition they can receive the
value of the cash account no they can't
not ELISA Sabine not unless it's an a be
universal in which case you pay more for
it to start with no that is not true are
you talking about paid up Editions Padma
are you talking about paid up Editions
no I'm not talking about paying up
additions there is a you have something
called the fifth dividend option sure
well absolutely the bottom line is at
the end of the day the people don't get
the cash value you pay twenty times more
and the cash value is not added on now I
mean you can look at every major whole
life company that's out there and you
tell me they get their cash values they
don't get them listen here's the
situation dude I can talk to you and for
the rest of my life and I'm not gonna
tell you I'm not gonna talk you into not
selling whole life I'm not even talking
about whole life or time I sell a lot of
term bundles but you still sell the
other crap too and I defend it because I
scrap now let me ask you another
question yeah by the way for your
information just so I'm not arguing with
you but the cash value the amount of the
value on top of the face of the policy
can be paid to the beneficiary if the
policy is written appropriately and none
of them are written that way well I've
written them that way for thirty five
years
no it just doesn't happen do you not
know that that you and I know that that
is not how the industry is set up well
it is the other thing is you said that
you know you talk about whole life as
being such a horrible product and again
maybe in your mind it is but can I ask
you this question why is that particular
product that particular product that you
think is so deplorable but by many
publicly held companies and privately
held companies to fund buyouts
of corporate stock and there's a lot
about some agreements that use whole
life and you know why because people
like you sell that crap too that's
exactly why they do it
a simple partnership buy sell agreement
can be funded with term life insurance
usually one twentieth of the cost well
let me ask you this do you know how many
publicly held fortune 500 companies use
whole life and the millions of dollars
the boards of directors authorized but
that it's really sad that they're all
getting screwed at that level well
really is because it's a garbage Russ I
think they know a little bit more than a
lot than a lay person well they may or
they may not but the bottom line is is
that at the end of the day dude this is
it is the payday lender of the middle
class it's it's a horrid product when
you pay twenty times more for the same
amount of coverage to build up a cash
value that you never receive because
when you die they pay the face amount
Russ so I can argue with you like I can
argue with a brick for the rest of my
life and the bricks still gonna be a
brick and so when you and I finish
talking you'll still be a whole life
agent and I'll still be right
so conversation over dude thank you for
calling in
you